five leading roles five limitless
actresses here are the nominees for
actress in a leading role Penelope Cruz
in volver Judi Dench and notes on a
scandal Helen Mirren and Meryl Streep
and the double wife Kate Winslet and
little chicken and the Oscar goes to
Helen Mirren in the Queen
the road to the Oscars was bumpy for
heaven
an Indian hand reader once told her that
her success would not be until her late
40s
got my past in one hand my earring in
the other Thank You Academy thank you so
much
huge honor you know my sister told me
that all kids love to get gold stars and
this is the biggest and the best gold
star that I have ever had in my life I
want to share my gold star with my
fellow nominees those brilliant
brilliant actresses who gave such
amazing performances this year I also
share my gold star with the film makers
with Stephen Frears with Peter Morgan
with Andy Harris and all the producers
and all the film makers in the cast
thank you now you know for 50 years and
more Elizabeth Windsor has maintained
her dignity her sense of duty and her
hairstyle
she's had her feet planted firmly on the
ground her hat on her head her handbag
on her arm and she's weathered many many
storms and and I salute her courage and
her consistency and I thank her because
for her if it wasn't for her I most most
certainly would not be here ladies and
gentlemen I give you the Queen thank you
thank you very much